let us reintroduce in the extension to
context we're looking clinics and I gave
you my perplexing question I said
starting folks of Jamaican features it
should not be that difficult to migrate
over to equation and therefore by
specimen why it's thanks meter right
except I bet your experience you little
bit difficulty right like you're looking
at it then it's maybe unless you have
supply knowledge just based on this
right if you're scratching your head
then there's a good reason for them okay
now the whole reason for me putting you
through that is so that you said I'm
about to run you through a fairly
involved proof okay now once we get to
the end of that proof this problem okay
but I need you to make sense
there's no point taking pad at all
before you have a headache right like if
you don't know all this is what it feels
like for my brain to feel like it's
about to explode inside my skull it
padded all is meaningless to you but if
you're ever really experienced a bad
headache and then taken perhaps a ball
and then for to just bad you could go
away you're like this is amazing right
so I want you to remember this trying to
get from this to where are these things
this is like I'm Goku searching every
room and I'm like just hitting dance
right let me show you how to get out of
it
no this is gonna be a bit unusual I'm
gonna hijack the diagram but I have to
because I've got something others if you
don't have or if you already put your
numbers onto the diagram for this what
I'd like you to do is draw me a new one
but it needs to be at least the width of
an apex like it needs to be at least
that one and what I say that why I mean
including where the directories aren't
going to be right so I'm expecting that
on your lips is it gonna occupy baby
like a half of the middle of the page I
think this should be a fair margin of
the side of birth but we've got this
other three nice and large because the
arguments are about to tour isn't it
three visual will be very difficult to
see if Jennifer died so I will give you
a second to catch up on that because uh
I don't want to start by information
before you plug the diagram and ready so
enjoy yourself your lips
and it will stop
or your lips you'll need this for the
directress ease let's see where they are
but but of everything else
now just as you're drawing that I sought
a [ __ ] of this but just to make it
explicit right you do know how sometimes
I'll show you a proof like the proof for
y log X on X as X appears a pity why
does it threaten 1 0 right
and sometimes I'll pull out a step and
you'll be like weird that I tried to
avoid doing that in this case right like
the reason why I'm going to try to
explain this is so that you can see like
I solve this problem this isn't just oh
why do we bother proving this result
it's cuz there's a really difficult
toggle with the counter and it's very
hard to it's insoluble basically unless
you don't few extra things
yes insoluble is a great word about you
say every excuse I kid
punch to the check
that's not what soulful means
so do you member a few months ago and at
many times in between I often say to you
the reason why we introduced notation or
language terminology new words Makani
the reason why we do that is because
language is powerful language gives you
a lens for understanding and
interpreting and explaining and
communicating right so there's a whole
bunch of features on here that we know
about we know that we've got focus we've
got a directrix actually we've got
multiple words you already know this
ellipse come Center somewhere but
there's all kinds of things here which I
don't have language for that I want to
be able to talk about so look up for a
second if you should not finish through
this point that's okay
so we would say some words I want you to
clearly see where they got money do you
remember one of the reasons why we do
that there are two first I have two
directors is because we said the ellipse
is symmetrical in many different ways
right unlike a circle which has an
infinite number of axes of symmetry and
ellipse has only two in this case what
are the two axes isn't you there the
axes there the coordinate axes right so
then for on this particularly I'm going
to give their names right now can you
see I'm going to do it
Yeah right across the middle
this is one of the axes of symmetry and
it's the longer one right so since it's
longer than this other one we call this
axis that major axis
the major axis okay if that's the major
axis then it stands to reason that you
would call the other one the smaller one
the minor axis very much
that's the my taxes
now at the same time even though the
major axis and the Minor axis are
important to me I actually also very
interested in what's half of each of
those right that's kind of like the
radius for a circle but as we've already
established there is the radius key
because it's there close to me but if I
said well what is ma of the major axis
right when you say what's half of a
circle you call it up semicircle
so we call the half of the major axis
the semi-major axis it's a bit of a
mouthful but when you know where it
comes from
it's an axis it's the one on one major
and it's half of them sitting in exactly
the same way I got half of the minor
axis I'm going to call that the semi
minor axis
I hope you can see why I asked you to
draw my logic it's getting busy and it's
gonna get busy
now this separatists and semi-minor axis
in this context because I have drawn my
lips editor it's a horizontal ellipse
okay in the same way that parabolas can
be vertical travelers or horizontal
premise this is a horizontal ellipse the
semi-major axis is this X leg appear in
excellent I actually know what the
length of this thing is from when I
worked out the intercepts before do you
remember like in this case here for the
actual image we've got plus or minus 4
and for the y-axis we've got plus or
minus 3 right so therefore no excuse me
since in this context this distance is 4
units and this one's 3 generalize it to
this right if I have a horizontal one
and a is bigger and being smaller and
that is usually in a way to write the
semi-major axis is just going to be
equal to a would you agree with that but
that's what that link is and the city
prior axes are slightly is because you'd
be
there it's out that's a lot of words
it's a lot of words I'm not quite
there's one other extra new word that
I'm gonna introduce and unfortunately
even though you know how excited I am on
how much how important the means and
words are I can't tell you just yet what
this word means
it's stupid spoiler so do you remember
what we had a look at the big parabola
right we said the locus stuff like this
right and I said well this is a ratio in
describing it's this ratio yeah this is
a problem
then we looked about with it we said
change the ratio and I believe the ratio
that we tried first was 1/2
do you recall that yeah and when we did
that we ended up with an ellipse so
clearly this ratio matters this ratio is
important we really tried three values
at the moment but it's so important it
gets its name that's the way things are
in the world if something is significant
people talk about they give it a name so
this ratio the distance to the focus or
the distance to the directrix that ratio
we call that the eccentricity
the eccentricity of the curve okay now
if you're a clearly you might be able to
start to work out like what that word
means still they'll be able to get like
but why is it happened this means in
this context we would get there by the
end stop compromise this number we call
it eccentricity
because eccentricity starts with E the
Permira we use to indicate it is e which
is a which is a big deal it's a big deal
given that is one of the superstars of
mathematics right in this context
because we are not within any sign of
exponential graphs or logs this e in
this context and context of colleagues
and polynomials like like these guys and
these guys these reflection
eccentricities so we see e in this
context that's what